olivier mois là c'est juste qu'elle n'a
pas été rémunérée que j'aime passer de
ces en fait ça fait polémique on le sait
tous ce qu'est minceur tout ce qui
touche à la minceur et qui est
promotionner sur les réseaux ces
polémiques et là en fait je pense
qu'elle s'en sert en tu peux aussi faire
du buzz en disant c'est des voyous ces
machins mais actuellement magali le plus
protégé dans le droit à l'image c'est ce
qu'ont à l'ouvragé votre image
non alors elle a entièrement raison et
elle a raison c'est moi les locales et
géo complet désaccord avec l'animatrice
de foire agricole
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire que
vous arrivez chez moi mon image a été
pillé non pour pouvoir qu'elle produit
ça m'intéresse beaucoup à ce que masque
de vampires mon physique est extrêmement
populaire notamment dans l'équipe on
n'écarte pas mon visage a été pillée
pour des sites de rencontre avec
quelqu'un mais ne riez pas de même pour
les faire interdire malin je la
comprends tout à fait il ya donc un site
de rencontre plus digne de ce nom qui a
pris votre visage
et oui bon pour votre émotion mais il ya
des choix qui m'ont fizir plaît monsieur
[Rires]
c'est un site de serial
qui leur était pas possible lassé
réfléchissez avant de rencontrer